your most excited space is a week good
run how old were you when you first down
12. you remember your first time not my
very first in-game I was probably 13.
how old were you when you first came to
the basketball I remember trying to do
it at like uh yeah 14. best player that
you played against so far it's got to be
um me early with Mike James tough shot
maker when you you think you defend good
you actually don't and he scores on you
yeah my little brother Oscar when he
comes into the league is there a player
they're most excited to block I'm
excited to block my first three-pointer
what's your least favorite
what people to tell you in the street or
whatever what's your most favorite I
guess I gotta pretty much like a general
like overview of the of everything